.
WAIT UNTIL IT'S COMES TO THE
GREAT LAKES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SO, TO SOMEONE WHO IS NOT IN THE
BUSINESS, YOU WERE SELLING OFF
AN ASSET LIKE THIS, ALLOWING IT
TO BE SOLD TO CHINA.
THAT SEEMS CRIMINAL.
>> YOU ARTICULATE JUST ABOUT
BETTER THAN ANYBODY.
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION, WE HAVE
TO ASK OURSELVES HOW WE GOT HERE
IN THE FIRST PLACE?
HOW DID WE REPLACE ONE BAD
POLICY WITH ANOTHER ONE?
HOW DO WE GO FROM BEING THE
WORLD ENERGY SUPERPOWER, BEING
NUMBER ONE IN OIL AND GAS AND
COAL AND GEOTHERMAL, SECOND AND
WIND AND SOLAR, TO SHAKING THE
TIN CUP TO THE SAUDIS AND NOT
EVEN BEING ABLE TO TRACK --
WHERE THESE RELEASES END UP?
IT'S QUITE DISCONCERTING.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THAT THE PRODUCTION COMPANIES
WERE NOT SUPPORTIVE OF THEIR
RELEASE.
WHY WEREN'T WE ALLOWED TO OPEN
UP WHAT WE WERE DOING, VERSUS
SHUTTING THAT OFF AND TAPPING IN
TO THE TENACIOUS CREDIT CARD?
IT'S FRUSTRATING.
>> I TALKED TO MOST OF THE
PEOPLE WHO RUN THESE GAS
COMPANIES.
THEY ALL ACT LIKE THEY ARE
SELLING CIGARETTES TO KIDS.
WHY DON'T THEY STEP UP IN PUBLIC
AND SAY "WITHOUT US, THIS IS AN
IMPOVERISHED COUNTRY, YOU NEED
US TO STAY SOLVENT," AND MAKE
NOISE AND FIGHT BACK?
>> WE ARE TRYING TO.
THE TWEET THE PRESIDENT SET OUT
SATURDAY, WE HAD THAT RESPONSE.
YOU KNOW HOW IT IS.
TWITTER IS AN EXERCISE IN
FUTILITY.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO THINK THEY
ARE EXPERTS IN OIL AND GAS
BECAUSE THEY RETWEET SOMETHING A
CELEBRITY DOES.
WE AVOIDED IT, BUT WE SAW THAT
TWEET COME ACROSS, AND IT STRUCK
A NERVE.
WE DID OUR BEST TO CALL B.S. ON
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> IT'S OVER IF WE GET RID OF
FOSSIL FUELS, AND T